I love you I think you're beautiful
there's no stripper that looks better
than you I know that's right affirm your
wife Joy I will make a promise to you
right now I will not go back to a strip
club Joy vows to never return to the
strip club unless you are with me after
Yara opens up to him about how insecure
it makes her feel about her body how do
you think it makes me feel when I see
that you likes to go and watch other
woman's naked and while I am glad to
hear him say all of this that's that's a
big promise for someone who's been going
consistently for over 15 years I'm
intimidated for him
plus let's go get a
drink Kanani and asell commit to their
new lives as co-parents leading to this
beautiful moment where the cast dances
the night
[Music]
away hold my head
on yeah this is 90day replay travel size
where I pack in all you need to know
while keeping it light hey 90day fans
famam It's Mia I absolutely loved the
Last Resorts finale it was so
heartwarming but before we get into the
best part in my opinion let's talk about
Yar breaking down in tears in front of
the therapist over jy's behavior during
the couple's last group therapy session
we are in
doy what are you feeling about this
relationship right now who'd like to
start it's been a rough day well like
Joy start because I don't want to talk B
about my husband and about about father
of my child so let Jo to start you can
tell them what happened I don't want to
please I don't want to I was like girl
say you don't understand why he likes
stripper so much say it so y'all could
have this conversation with
professionals I messaged the stripper
that I previously knew
knew I don't know how to express that
like for us as the guys last night we
thought it was a fun time Yara stays
quiet as Joy tells the therapist what
went down and for some reason a larger
conversation about why Joy is quote
obsessed with the strip club still
didn't happen it's loow hanging fruit at
this point I don't understand why it's
not being addressed fast forward to the
morning of the commitment ceremony Yara
has a conversation with Dr pety and we
learn that her choice to stay quiet
about the strip club drama with Joie was
actually less about respecting him and
more about her feeling ashamed and
embarrassed by his behavior why do you
feel you have to feel shame for his
behaviors because he's my husband and I
choose him and because he's the father
of my child in the place where I grew up
specifically like you need to be
especially if you're a girl you need to
be a perfect you need to be super smart
you need to be beautiful you need to
know how to clean cook and if you done
somebody going to talk about you and
love from you and basically shame you
yeah and the most like common words for
mother say to the child is like are you
not shamed to do that you shouldn't be
shamed to do
that bne brown who uses research to
study shame says shame is the most
powerful Master emotion it is the fear
that we are not not good enough wow what
would the world look like if we all
truly believe we are good
enough it will probably solve most of
the world's problems bernee goes on to
say that giving yourself Grace is key
meaning that all of your mistakes and
quote unquote imperfections now serve a
purpose instead of serving shame they
always joke on me my cousins everybody
so I'm just trying to get to the perfect
level of the time in yara's case instead
of feeling ashamed about jy's behavior
and their relationship not being perfect
at this point she can reframe how she's
looking at it jy's actions the other day
were unacceptable but now they're
leading them to have a necessary and
meaningful conversation about their
marriage that'll hopefully make them
closer and allow them to move forward in
a better
Direction it's crazy how much peace you
can receive and how much can be solved
just by changing your perspective what
is that for you to go to the strip club
that you feel like you need to go there
fast forward Joy apologizes to Yara for
texting the stripper and going to the
strip club behind her back I love you I
think you're beautiful there's no
stripper that looks better than you if
you feel that I'm so sorry that you feel
that way it makes me feel bad about
myself because you're choosen to go
watch another woman than watch your
woman and spend time with her yep
perfectly said Yara I think I am not a
freaking ugly waiting for you at home
you're perfect and it's not about you
and I want you to know that as a words
of affirmation girl what JY is saying
right now sounds like music to my ears
tell her again oh perfect and it's not
about you and I want you to know
that you choosing not to spend time with
me you choosing to go and watching Other
Woman it does hurt me I tell you about
my insecurities I'm so freaking insecure
about my body I do know like my but you
see how much freaking I am like obsessed
with go to the gym and go to the stuff
and look and all that stuff so how do
you think it makes me feel when I see
that you likes to go and watch other
woman's naked the power of the
commitment ceremony I have never seen
these two communicate so openly and well
I didn't understand that you felt that
way if I would have understood that
maybe I could have done a better job of
not doing things that hurt you okay so
if you don't want me to do that and
you're expressing your emotions to me I
will not go back cuz I didn't think that
I was hurting you the way that you're
telling me now and I believe him but
it's still like wow how could you not
think of that is it a man thing I knew
that Yara didn't like me going to strip
clubs but I thought that she was just
being a protective wife I didn't know
that going to strip clubs was causing
her to feel more insecure knowing how
much this has hurt her I do regret going
I didn't think that this would affect
her in such a negative way right I
didn't I didn't know everything that was
really bothering her and the reasoning
behind her not wanting me to go to a
strip club JY goes on to make a huge
promise to Yara I will not go back to a
strip club unless you are with me cuz I
don't think that's necessary for me to
do that and even if it's for a fun night
out with the guys I'm not going to do
that obviously our marriage is much more
important than that I hope he stays a
man of his word meanwhile Yara has her
doubts he's hard for me to trust you
right now because you promised me
already so much stuff we can make it
better you tell me this you tell me all
the time something and doesn't mean that
it's happening and you see this is the
problem too because you're dropping the
promises which sometimes you cannot hold
it I'm sorry you need to think more
deeply about that look at Yara
channeling her inner therapist you need
to think more deeply about
that therapy will do that give you a
whole new language for dealing with
people in your life remember Big Ed was
talking about some how can I support you
I love that these are divorce papers all
right let's move on to the commitment
ceremony
Angela rips up the divorce papers she
brought just in case Michael didn't act
right thank you
Dy thank you I can't get him
refiled just let know Michael on this
iPad has been cracking me
up
technology they made it work for Angela
and Michael kudos to the production team
I commit to being a better friend to you
and to building a good good friendship
Kanani and asell commit to friendship
and co-parenting together although asell
admits he's struggling today is like a
worst day of my life I just want to
apologize for everything that I tweat
you and done bad to you and hurt your
feelings I just hope
that you uh forgive what I did
and all the past that we have I just
want you to let it go and just make a
new
friendship and I just want us to love
and respect to each other and Trust to
each other from here to the Future
speaking of that Yar and joy commit to
building trust in their relationship I
want to work on communicating with you
better and building trust with each
other cuz cuz that's one of the biggest
things we had issues
with I want to make you feel loved I
want to make you feel beautiful and I
want to give you and Mila more of my
time I want to give you more special
romantic moments to make you feel
appreciated and I love the way that you
have changed me to be a better
person y's comments to JY were also
really sweet I just want to start from
the fact that you are super loving
husband and you are the best dad in the
world and I'm going to cry right now
you're daddy that I must ever dream of
Mila is so happy to have you and I am so
happy to have you and I just want to be
the same to you a good wife as I am a
mother as we're both parents to our
buka the commitment ceremony ends with
Liz proposing to Big
Ed she loves him she loves that man I
love you I I will move to Arkansas with
you and I have one more thing for you oh
no will you marry me oh my God Angela
how did you get
that oh my
God I want you to have this ring so you
know that I am forever committed to
you wow yes I will marry
there is somebody for everybody y'all
okay now this is when my favorite part
of the episode begins it's time for the
couples and colani and ASU to
celebrate let go get a
drink colani and ASU run off as friends
and next thing we see is this beautiful
dinner setup on the beach everyone is in
a great mood joy and Ed literally
kissing makeup after Joy swung on Ed
last last episode I will punch you in
the face you bring
my might I add for a good reason and
then the music starts playing and the
loving Parts about these 90day cast
members just come
out one more
[Music]
time Angela gives Michael a little Skype
strip
[Music]
teas I can't I'm running away and our
swell goes from looking completely
brokenhearted to showing off his goofy
side again and having a little bit of
joy in his eyes watching this put the
biggest smile on my face I'm proud of
90day great job great first season of
The Last Resort now season two can we
get Gino and Jasmine in there that's who
I want to see let me know who you want
to see in the comments all right 90day
fans famam make sure you sick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next
time
oh